this one's daily wire says Georgia
Democrat Stacey Abrams said in a
recently service video that at six weeks
unborn babies heartbeats aren't real but
are a manufactured sound design a rather
a manufactured sound designed to take
away women's rights
Abrams is again campaigning to be the
governor of Georgia after a failed run
in 2018. notably the Democrat refused to
traditionally concede the race to
Republican Governor Brian Kemp
suggesting voter suppression and a
broken system so we have that clip and
let's brief clip let's listen to it
there is
foreign
manufactured sale designed to convince
people that men
have all of the moon's body weight
that is
one of the most deranged conspiracy
theories I've ever heard in my life
not only so there's no heartbeat it's
manufactured and it is specifically
manufactured so I guess when you go in
for the ultrasound the ultrasound tech
is part of a wide-ranging far-right
conspiracy
to convince you that babies are people
when really they are this is all a
conspiracy and the and the ultrasound
text they're in on it they're all a
bunch of Nazis and far-right extremists
terrorists
Glenn Kessler is a fact checker for the
Washington Post he came to Stacy's
defense of course says for what it's
worth
fetal heartbeat is a misnomer the
ultrasound picks up electrical activity
generated by an embryo the so-called
heartbeat sound that you hear is created
by the ultrasound not not until 10 weeks
can the opening and closing of cardiac
valves be detected by a Doppler machine
now look I'm tempted to just say
um just like I would say to John okay
you want to go and and believe that
we're that all we care about is tax cuts
for billionaires that's fine and here
I'm tempted to say okay fine if you guys
want to go out there and make the
argument that uh well it's okay to kill
the baby because the heartbeat isn't
technically a heartbeat
the heartbeat is it's a it's all part of
a cons
the fetal heartbeat is a right-wing
conspiracy if you want that to be your
argument especially going into the
midterms then go for it put it on a
bumper sticker I I encourage you put it
on poster boards put it on signs March
down the street fetal heartbeat is a
right-wing conspiracy
go ahead
um if you want to parse the definition
of heartbeat in order to justify
destroying human life
if you want to expose yourself in that
way
then go ahead
I stipulate if you want to expose
yourself in that way I don't mean in
like a Jeffrey tubing kind of way but we
should note here even so that they're
wrong so to fact check the fact Checker
back to the Daily wire articles as a
peer-reviewed science has found the
following the non-profit Charlotte
Lozier Institute has outlined quote
um
the heart the heart is actively beating
at six weeks between a conception and
birth the baby's heart will beat
approximately 54 million times
the baby's average heartbeat is uh 98
BPM this will rise to 175 BPM by nine
weeks gestation the presence of a
heartbeat at six to eight weeks
gestation correlates with a live birth
rate of 98 in normal pregnancies without
intervention
the brain has divided into three primary
sections responsible for sensing and
decision making moving and tracking
objects and vital bodily functions eyes
ears and nose start forming so that's
all what's happening at six weeks also
by the way we should note that um even
on planned parenthood's website up until
just now they also acknowledge that the
heartbeat starts at six weeks
interestingly enough now after this went
viral Stacey Abrams they changed it to
make their even though it had been there
for years they changed it to put it more
in line with what Stacey Abrams said
so there is a heartbeat of six weeks
but think about the wording
going back to uh Glenn Kessler think
about the wording
he says the heartbeat is six weeks he
says is really just electrical activity
by the embryo that's all it's electrical
activity generated by an embryo
well he's right of course
but then you could say that about the
heartbeat at any age
okay we could say that about Glenn
Kessler's heartbeat that's just
electrical activity being generated by
the body you could reduce any human at
any age
down to Mere mechanical functions if you
want
that can Glenn Kessel he's just a
skeleton covered with organs and muscle
and skin walking around
that's all he is
I mean you really you get into he's just
like he's a bag of bones and flesh
walking that's all he is
Glenn Kessler he's a he's a collection
of atoms that's all he is
you care that much about one little atom
so you take one little one little tiny
atom and we don't care about that and
then you add a bunch of them and make
Glenn Kessler and suddenly he matters
you can use that language to dehuman uh
D person anyone
but it is strange it's strange how
selective the left and the media can
tend to be
on on this subject when exactly uh
in in what scenarios are we
acknowledging the personhood and
Humanity of unborn children so here's a
report the exact same day this is going
on The Today Show has a report
which also has to deal with you know
those quote fetuses that just generate
electricity that's all they do well
let's talk let's watch this
wait so you guys have to see this have
you heard about this so this morning we
wanted to show you I'm trying to change
the subject some amazing baby faces look
at this so researchers in Britain wanted
to know if babies in the womb react when
the mom ingests the flavor of food and
this is what they saw do you want to
guess what was on the left
so the left is a baby in its resting
state and then on the right you see how
he smiles 20 minutes the mom made some
carrots oh on the left with the there
was just a resting seat that was
arresting but he liked the carrots she
had like a carrot pill so were there
other Foods yes there were other Foods
I'm glad you asked you want to look at
this Baby's reaction before Mama kale
wow wow so here's the thing what about
if Mama had ice cream I don't know why
why would they go why would they go with
Let Me Explain vegetables so the studies
co-author says the images could just
show muscle movements when a baby's
reacting to maybe a flavor that's bitter
so you shouldn't interpret it whether
you know it's happy or distaste no I
think that's how I do yeah because once
they get out of the womb it's that same
look yeah it's the same way yeah
but it just goes to show you know what
you ingest yeah you are what you eat and
the 3D imagery is pretty cool they
didn't have that when I was pregnant did
you get three yeah I got 3D honestly
Ollie and Rusty look exactly like they
do 3D images
my kids had chalk drawings
every single person up there on camera
all four of them
would adamantly support so-called
abortion rights
so when it comes to babies experiencing
taste from the food that their mother is
eating
when it comes to that it's all they're
cute look at those little babies
but if we're talking about actually
executing those same babies in the womb
then they're just
collection of cells a clump of cells is
all
let me ask you something if a baby can
react to Brussels sprouts and kale
in the womb
uh do you think that the child might
react to being physically tortured and
torn apart limb from limp
might there be a reaction to that
if the baby can experience sensation
taste
what's the experience of um
being being
torn apart dismembered while you're
still alive
which is how they perform these
abortions especially the later stages
3D technology is also it's I mean it's
almost miraculous it's incredible
but that only goes to show how on the
conservative side of the pro-life side
uh we line up with science
okay we are the pro science side because
science
only continues ever more to vindicate
our position
you know the more the more we learn
about what is happening in the womb you
know the more we learn about human
development
the more horrific and barbaric abortion
becomes
well if you enjoyed that video be sure
to hit the Subscribe button and ring the
bell to get more content like it if
you're craving more content go watch or
listen to my full show at dailywire.com
Spotify or wherever you get your podcast